aren't you sick of
politicians who stand up for election
and
campaign every 2 years in the house
every six years in the Senate and say I
love
Israel and then when it comes time to St
and tall when things are tough for
Israel where do they
go they shrink into the
shadows and let the Obama
Administration dictate to them what the
policy should be Visa the United States
and Israel a shift away from
Israel those aren't politicians that are
Standing Tall it's easy to say that you
love
Israel but it takes courage to stand up
and actually back up your words with
deeds and it's about time that all
Americans but particularly Jewish
Americans judge the candidates that they
vote for by Deeds not words
[Applause]
Ronald
Reagan was one of those
politicians that said what he meant and
did what he said I was
here I was here when Ronald Reagan
addressed this
congregation I was fortunate enough to
get a ticket my brother was working in
the Reagan
Administration I had wor worked for
Ronald Reagan before he became president
I was on his staff his campaign staff
and then I went to law school and could
no longer work with him but it was one
of the proudest days in my life as an
American and as a Jew to be here in this
Hall in this
sh and witness the first American
President since George
Washington to address a Jewish
congregation in their synagogue it took
200 years George Washington was the
first at turo synagogue in Newport Road
Island so Ronald Reagan was a man of
Courage a man who backed up his words we
have someone like that today who's a
neighbor of ours
his name is Peter
King Peter King put my name into
nomination at the Republican convention
he is the honorary chairman of my
campaign Peter King is the ranking
member on the house
Homeland Security
committee Peter King is the author and
sponsor of the resolution America stands
by
[Music]
Israel Peter King could not find one
Democrat to co-sponsor that
resolution and what did that resolution
say that resolution merely said that we
weren't going to spend the
hardworking taxpayer dollars of the
American people on a kangaroo court on
the Human Rights Council of United
Nations a council that is biased against
Israel biased against the west and
biased against the United
States could not find one Democrat to
co-sponsor that
resolution 37 Republicans
[Applause]
today
today there has not been a sponsor in
the United States Senate for that
resolution I pledge to you today that
when I am elected United States Senator
I will sponsor Peter King's resolution
in the United States Senate
ladies and
gentlemen we are in grave times
now we are in Crossroads in
America America can go in One
Direction which I think is a path to
mediocrity or we can go and get back on
the right
track based on the principles that made
this the greatest nation in the
world we have a president
who just doesn't get it we have a
president who doesn't stand firmly
behind Israel because he sees the world
through a different set of
eyes he sees the United States role in
the world through a different set of
eyes I could not disagree with President
Obama more fundamentally
and on his policies towards Israel his
overall foreign policy and his weakness
in homeland
security I have
[Music]
called I have called for the resignation
of Attorney General Eric
we cannot separate the war against
Israel with the war against Terror Hamas
Hezbollah
Al-Qaeda they were all rotten fish in
the same
cin and we have to treat it as a global
war on
terror and we have to understand that
there are people out there every
plotting to do
harm not only against Israel but against
the United States how much time go
have two more minutes okay I want to hit
a couple of subjects first of all
Homeland Security Eric
Holder I don't know if you're aware of
this or not but there are nine lawyers
in the Justice Department who are in the
terrorist enforcement
division who represented terrorists as
defendants
now one or two or maybe three could be a
coincidence but
nine you know terrorists don't find
their lawyers in the Yellow Pages they
don't get a referral from the bar
association it's usually lawyers who may
not agree with terrorist methods but
they agree with their philosophy and
these are the people in charge of
enforcing the laws against terrorists I
lost my nephew on September 11th he was
from this community meow meia Park he
was a volunteer firef fighter in this
community he was an Army veteran and he
was a New York state court officer Tomy
Jurgens he went into Tower 2 carried a
woman up to
safety and his Lieutenant said Tommy it
looks pretty dangerous here I think we
ought to abandon the rescue my nephew
said I'm not leave until everybody's out
those were his last words we never
recovered his remains only his sidearm
and his shield
but you know what his brother didn't
give up my other nephew is a New York
City firefighter and guess where he's
stationed two blocks away from the World
Trade Center so we're not going to get
back we're not going to get
back last
thing I'm running out of time I could
talk about the issues affecting Israel
and American foreign policy for probably
hours just want to make one point
I believe that it is the United States
responsibility to make sure that Iran
does not get nuclear weapons
capability and I know there are some
people that would like to see Israel do
our dirty work for us but the fact of
the matter is that once Iran gets nule
nuclear
capability it is the first step to be
end of this this world as we know it
because everybody in the Middle East
will be armed with nuclear weapons and
with the lunatics that they have there
someone's going to sheet one off they're
going to start a nuclear Holocaust and
we can't allow that could happen so I
think the United States needs to step up
to the plate and get serious about not
only a threat to Israel but a threat to
World Peace a threat to each and every
one of us the last thing I want to do is
end talking about Ronald Reagan someone
who I greatly admire Ronald Reagan said
there is a
reason why
America was put between those two
magnificent oceans and the reason is we
are Mankind's best hope I believe that
I've traveled 16,000 mi in my own car
throughout the state and I'm here to
tell you New York workers have not lost
faith in America they've lost faith in
their leaders I'm running to restore
your faith in the leadership of this
country thank you
God
thank I understand I got 11 seconds left
but just before I do I want to recognize
some some friends Howard copel our
County legislator over s down here dear
friend of a strong supporter of Israel
and I just want to say a word about Gary
burnson I've known Gary burnson out for
a number of years uh Gary was a uh an
operative I guess that's the most I can
say about your service in the Central
Intelligence ageny Gary thank you for
your service to this
country
well I can't get insight um the question
was why hasn't Senator
gilland sponsored Pete
King's resolution for America to stand
by
Israel I I can't go into her thought
processes all I can say is that she's
been absolutely silent time and time
again on issues that are important to
Israel issues that are important to
Homeland Security issues that are
important to National Security and maybe
she's afraid
that Chuck
Schumer will frown upon her if she takes
a step away from her step away from him
or a step away from President Obama's
policies Gary's too polite to say the
reason why Chuck Schumer has backed away
from Israel it's because he wants to be
Majority Leader so he'll do just about
anything that Barack Obama wants him to
do to
[Music]
become
person person jbrand was appointed by
Governor Patterson in a deal with with
Senator Schumer and President Obama
protected her from a primary so she owes
them a lot and I guess maybe she won't
get tickets to the Kennedy Center or to
a state dinner or whatever but it's a
real lack of courage and it's a big
difference between me and Senator Jill
BR thank you for asking my
[Applause]
question my grandson is a New York City
firefighter and I wear this bracelet for
his brother-in-law who also died in 9
thank you thank you for his
service
F well we're going to repeal the bad
deal that's
how we're going to defund it all
that go ahead
I heard that all through the campaign
don't worry don't worry R Emanuel is
going to be his chief of staff don't
worry don't worry well you know
what
unfortunately there are people in this
world that put ambition ahead of
principle and I'm here to tell you today
that I am running for United States
Senate not for ambition not for the
title but because I see this country
going in the wrong direction and every
generation before me sacrificed so I
could have the opportunities that I had
and this is the first generation in a
100 years that's predicted to do worse
than the previous generation and I just
could not sit on the sidelines and let
my son inherit a world that didn't have
as much opportunity as I did thank you
God bless you all